have you seen this i i i no i haven't
watched this whole thing that's the
thing we were talking about this in
crypto.com and everything by the way
kyle just told me that they're putting
up
they took down the staples letters
they're putting up the krypto.com
letters on christmas day oh just
it's just
yeah yeah let's watch this ad with matt
damon that we were talking everyone
strive in prepare to be um
yeah
yeah prepare to be condescended okay
yeah
history is filled with almost
with those who almost adventured
who almost achieved
but ultimately
for them it proved to be too much
then there are others
the ones who embrace the moment
and commit
and in these moments of truth he wanted
to say something else there at the
beginning he wanted to say like
uh who almost achieved but [ __ ] ate
[ __ ] instead slept on this market
these men and women
these
mere mortals oh just like you and me oh
as they peer over the edge oh
mere mortals just like you
yeah yeah not me though wait matt damon
yeah
i'm [ __ ] mad damon what if he paused
there just like
you
a little chuckle
just like
you you you know
calm their minds
and steal their nerves
with four simple words that have been
whispered by the intrepid since the time
of the romans i'm [ __ ] mad
let this go
fortune favors the break
mic draw
so [ __ ] you if you're listening on audio
yeah seriously
fortune favors the brave [ __ ] dude
[ __ ] you
so if you're just listening they just
compared buying bitcoin to um
space exploration
climbing mount everest the human flight
being a [ __ ]
like a roman legend i guess
like
and and they compared um not buying
bitcoin to um
what is that like a conquistador like
failing to discover another country in
1409
it was like a dude on a ship
like tapping out
oh yeah there's nothing for my country
to pillage failure we have to leave
ultimately wasn't for him yeah
that's what he said right
for them it proved to be two proved to
be too much
you know they went through like nine
revisions to get that like
to get that like palatable enough yeah
to say how do we
how do we like not be too
offensive to all the [ __ ] failures
out there yeah
because they don't see the power of
crypto i mean they're [ __ ] morons
okay that's that's what we have to
remind them of is they're [ __ ] stupid
and now's their chance to get a little
bit of cheese yeah
honestly i like this commercial yeah i
do i think i think uh
i think that it's
i just wanted to see the end crypto.com
yeah
i think that they i don't know that they
nailed what they were trying to do
now i think they did this is the chase
bank of crypto and
you know yeah because like the big banks
always have some like lightly
condescending commercial how so
get your bottom barrel uh checking
account that uh won't [ __ ] your life on
overdrafting yeah yeah yeah if you
overdraft a lot don't worry this card's
for you yeah do you always have a
negative balance that's okay yeah we'll
give you this perk that sounds like a
feature but we'll just let you skate to
the next paycheck [ __ ] you you know
where they're running this ad on cable
tv in south bend indiana yeah yeah
exactly is that how you saw it i saw it
on [ __ ] cable tv no way i was like oh
my god they're just gonna rinse every
person that's geriatric yeah
it's oh dude i was oh my god i was
listening to when i was driving through
bakersfield mm-hmm california you
thought about living there
i was like it's beautiful here yeah i
started looking at redfin like oh it
smells like [ __ ] i wonder if it was like
ass nothing around here
not even an airport
sick um
so isolated i love it
um
no i was listening to fm radio because
my phone was about to die and my
charging port broke so i couldn't do car
play or whatever so i was like cool
let's let's go old school
how many turn on the fm radio and it's
the baby and dude
oh like 50 times yeah like they played
the same five songs literally i know
people say that about fm radio but they
were going through the same five songs
like just going through like they just
were like no one listens to fm radio
this long so we could just play the same
[ __ ] over and over again and then it's
like 20 minutes of ads yeah between five
songs yeah and all the ads are they
scammy ass [ __ ] like one of them was a
coveted thermometer and the way that
they were pitching it was like
basically harping on the danger of covid
and the effects and you don't know where
it is in your community so then buy our
thermometer
to tell if you already have it nice
yeah but they were pitching like the
thermometer was gonna solve covid for
this community yeah it was really [ __ ]
up i was like this is a scam yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] that their mom and
they're gonna do that's where mcdonald's
runs all their like vaguely
like racist like radio ads like
the voice over on those is insane
it's you know
it's [ __ ]
it's just bad crypto.com
basically i think that's where they're
going to go next is fm radio ads yeah
probably yeah
do you have coven yeah
not if you own bitcoin you don't yeah do
you have code bitcoin is proven to be
the number one repellent against covent
symptoms it'll be like this
are you
over 60
is the final stage of life knocking on
your doors
you want to leave something behind for
the people
that you care about mm-hmm
you're at risk of covid you could go any
day now yeah
and you want to do something nice for
the family yeah so be brave
crypto.com also are you a fan of matt
damon movies
yes yes i am yes yes this is his voice
this is matt damon
talking to you right now matt matt talk
to me brother i think you should buy
bitcoin i will buy that bitcoin i will
on krypto.com
yeah i bought some bitcoin
yeah matt damon told me to do it on the
radio i love that man i loved him when
we see goodwill hunting
when we see a crypto.com ad with um
you know what they say mm-hmm
that's coming next maddie yeah maddie
mccons yeah that's when it's over
that is when it's [ __ ] over yeah
they're trying to get everybody you know
now that we're at the end of this
episode i think it's a good time to talk
about tether
okay
let's do it open up that reddit thread i
gotta read that but you can explain it
to me too
all right everyone if i talk about
crypto in the um
uh bog brother voice does it make it
more acceptable
do it pumped ones with tata and sends it
sideways tether is what what a stable
coin is it's something that's backed by
uh the american dollar one to one yeah
so for every tether that's created it
means that they have a dollar of
american currency in their reserves so
basically what it means is someone can
exit crypto trades like if they're in
bitcoin and they want to exit they can
exit into tether yes and that basically
without having to go to
uh dollars and that in begin in the
beginning was i guess to avoid like
taxable events or something like that uh
but it's also
so that they can make trades easier and
they don't have to go back and forth
between the dollar which is a tougher
thing to do yes so
now i guess tether is
the amount of tether that exists now is
like 68 billion dollars or something
yeah and it's supposed to all be backed
by
the us dollars and you know normally
people are like transparent about that
and how they
how they do that and what they actually
have in their reserves because it can't
just be money right they don't have 68
billion dollars sitting in an account
somewhere so they they are a buyer of
commercial paper which i guess is i
don't really know what it is but i guess
it's like some form of debt or something
right but
it would basically if they really did
had 68 billion dollars it would make
them like one of the biggest purchasers
of commercial paper in the world besides
like jp morgan or something like that
right and this is like a small company
yeah
of of people that do not
basically show zero transparency yeah
so what could happen here is like if
they find out if the world finds out
that
um
they don't actually have
the money to back up the amount of
tether that people are holding it could
basically crap crash the whole crypto
industry basically i think
yeah now correct me if i'm wrong on that
that was my shitty explanation but yeah
it's probably pretty crucial that you
understand that going in i just got so
excited to say that as a few days ago
they printed an additional 1.5 billion
worth of tether
as is phrased here literally out of thin
air
wow and then it says nowhere nowhere it
is documented where the money which was
just created comes from and where it
actually went
i was so before 2019 tether claimed 100
of its reserves would be backed by
actual cash suddenly in april 2019
tether claimed only 74 of tether was
backed by actual cash and cash
equivalents which is the commercial
paper basically so this so going off of
what you said
this was my thought and i didn't
actually get this deep in the body
because i was just so
like
amused with the fact that they printed
money i think they're trying to do the
fed thing where it's like oh no we have
this amount
you know it's unlikely that everyone
will cash at the same time yeah so
you know um we can continue to you know
purchase more debt and like you know
issue more [ __ ]
currency because we have this minimum
percentage
yeah of assets yep so they're 100 doing
the fed thing but
i mean
it could implode the crypto market or
what if it just does nothing because you
know our [ __ ] money is built on
[ __ ] yeah
yeah exactly that's doing the same thing
kind of gene cash out of nowhere yeah
kind of genius to be like what if we're
just the crypto fed yeah if we just do
it first yeah yep
evil man
you